you ask
i answer i i got a message maybe a week
or so ago from a listener to the show
maddie who wanted me to view
and debunk some viral tick tock by a
pro-abortion lady i have not
watched the tick tock yet i am eager
with anticipation to knock down the lies
of the pro-abortion movement now before
we get started this video is sponsored
by dwell dwell is the five-star app that
makes it easy to get into the bible by
providing a world-class listening
experience more from them later on for
now let's get into the crazy
tick-tock
arguments
all right i have an analogy for y'all
let's go so say you're driving and you
run a red light or you miss a stop sign
you cause an accident due to that
accident a life is at stake that person
that you hit requires a kidney
transplant and you are a match
should you be legally required to give
them your kidney
think about it now parallel situation
two people have sex and an accident
occurs pregnancy because of that
accident a life is at risk i have many
videos describing the medical device was
it here for a second obviously this is
an imprecise uh analogy that she's
making but it doesn't work as an analogy
because of the particulars but also
because of the premise
if you're driving and you get into a car
accident something has gone wrong the
purpose of driving is to get from point
a to point b safely and if you follow
all of the rules you you will do that
the purpose is not to get into the
accident the purpose of sexual
intercourse the tea loss the logical end
of sexual intercourse
is
procreation that is what it's for it's
not just for making you feel good it is
for making babies and so the accident
that you call it is not because
something has gone wrong in sexual
intercourse is because something has
gone right and so obviously there are
the rest of the analogy i think falls
apart too but even at its most basic
premise it doesn't work the car accident
is when something goes wrong when you're
driving procreation the conception of a
baby is when something goes right when
you're doing that thing that only
married people are supposed to do okay
go on how that actually that life
doesn't exist until week 24 we're taking
away that entire argument right now to
even show you that when we consider it a
life where the medical ethics lost hold
on pause right there so she said she
tried to slip that and she said life
doesn't exist until week 24. no one has
ever held that to be true scientifically
that's obviously preposterous
even historically even if you're going
to make some argument that about
quickening or insolent or even before we
had modern medical technology say let's
use the the physics of aristotle where
it was unclear when the signs of life
begin just because they didn't have
sonograms for instance and in the olden
days now we do even then no one said
that life doesn't begin until week
24. what happens at week 24 that doesn't
happen at week 23 and six days or week
23 and five days you might say that a
person doesn't have worth
until week 24. you are worthless eric
barry or until one year old or two years
old or whatever you want to say but you
can't say it's not life the moment and
now now we know this forget about old
uncle aristotle for a second we now know
this because of modern medical science
the moment that the sperm and the egg
meet almost instantaneously
those two separate organic things
disappear and there is a new organic
thing made with that genetic material
that has unique genetic material and all
of the signs of life including growth
which which begins
instantaneously so we're all supposed to
follow the science these days and just
trust the scientists and everything the
science is absolutely clear yes science
life begins at conception you might not
want to protect life at conception you
might say that certain life is not worth
protecting you might say that people
don't deserve to be protected from
murder until they're
24 weeks old or 40 weeks old or two
years old or three years old and you can
make some moral argument or i think an
immoral argument but you can try to make
that argument
the one thing you can't say is that it's
not life it manifestly is life and
specifically it's a human life it's not
a platypus it's not a giraffe it's not a
fish it's a human being okay go on so
due to the accident a life is at stake
the use of an organ is required in order
to save develop grow sustain whatever
you want to classify it as that life
that's at stake
so how is it different when a kidney is
required to save a life or a uterus is
required to grow a life because medical
ethics laws clearly sides with the owner
of that organ so
if
if i give my kidney to someone which is
a that's a wonderful thing to do for
somebody
i no longer have the kidney whether you
do murder your baby or you don't murder
your baby you're still going to have
your uterus right you're it's not though
as though you're giving your uterus to
someone even notice the language that
she uses here she says i i own my uterus
as if her body parts are somehow
different
than she is it's sort of other than she
is like i own my hands this is now very
common language with the transgender
movement you'll say you're a uterus
owner or a ovary owner or something to
me that is the
crazy extreme conclusion
of individualism of capitalism of
consumerism of whateverism you want to
say rather than recognize that your soul
and your body are one thing your body
mind and spirit are one thing
inextricably linked while we're on this
earth you're just looking at yourself as
a commodity you are looking at yourself
literally as just meat as a meat puppet
i am a meat popsicle and you own
that meat but it's much
i think
it's very simple or it's very easy
to fall into the error that she's
falling into of believing that you have
no connection to your own child that you
have no obligation or duty to your own
child it's easy to fall into that error
if you don't believe that you have any
duty or obligation or unity even with
your own body this is the kind of crazy
conclusion of the of my body
my choice but but the error begins even
before you start to think about your
other baby which which is why she's
thinking of the baby as some kind of
enemy or some kind of parasite rather
than what the baby is which is a baby
and a baby loves his mother and a mother
has obligations and loves her baby
here's a little trivia question what is
both the best-selling book of all time
and the best-selling book each and every
year
this is an easy one this is a gimme it
is the bible has been for a long time
and still is today we all know
even those who are agnostic even those
who are atheists often they'll know
they'll know that the bible is the
wisest book ever written
it has stood the test of time it is the
font of western civilization and yet
people don't take a lot of time to read
it people don't have time to read much
of anything at all so this is where
dwell comes in dwell is this terrific
app that will allow you to listen to the
bible you can pull up a bunch of
different versions the king james
version obviously i love the king james
version it's very beautiful language the
english standard
version they've got 12 different
narrators each with a unique accent the
niv the nkjb the esv the kjv a bunch of
versions really great way to get into
the bible to listen to it go to dwell
app dot io slash knowles to try dwell
free for seven days if you fall in love
with the app which i'm sure you will
they're giving all of our listeners
early access to their black friday sale
go to dwell app dot io knowles try dwell
for free for seven days begin your
journey of rediscovering wisdom and
truth in the bible all right go on
see the slippery slope and imagine a
world in which your bodily autonomy can
be ignored and your rights to ownership
over your organ is ignored and you pause
it there are two errors here the most
obvious one is your baby is not an organ
your baby is not your i guess your baby
has organs but they're his own organs
your baby is not one of your organs okay
so you don't have autonomy whatever that
even means over your baby moreover you
don't have total autonomy over yourself
you don't have the right to do whatever
you want to or with your body i used to
suck for coke i see them you have
certain obligations there is a
transcendent moral order that that's why
we're even having this debate in the
first place the pro-abortion people say
it is absolutely immoral to prevent
women from killing their babies and the
pro-life people are saying it's
absolutely immoral to kill your baby
well either way you come down on that
debate you're acknowledging that there
is a moral order and you have some
obligations to that moral order and so
her radical bodily autonomy stuff is
bunk it can't continue to exist if
you're acknowledging the existence of an
objective morality outside of your own
wishes and and will okay you have your
bodily autonomy stripped from you and
the use of your organ is no longer your
choice and see when we parallel it to a
situation like a kidney which is gender
and sex neutral and that's a scenario
that everyone can find themselves in now
think about whether the rights that you
have to your organ how you would feel if
they were removed and how the use of
your organ is no longer your decision
what kind of world is that and how is
that not a human rights violation
is that not a human rights violation so
we've pointed out that her analogy
doesn't really make sense but i'll take
it even further than that if your kid
needed an organ if your kid needed a
kidney or part of your liver or
something like that something that
wouldn't kill you but would save your
kid's life would you give it to your kid
of course you would
of course you would
any parent who is not a sociopath
would give his or her life
for his or her child
every single one
you can tell that this
woman does not have a baby because she's
spouting this kind of ignorance but of
course you would of course you would
she's looking at this issue primarily
from the vantage of rights
rights and entitlement and what's mine
and even if my helpless little
vulnerable baby needs something for me
even something that won't kill me won't
cause me great harm even something like
just being allowed to grow and gestate
for nine months and not being murdered
along the way i'm not going to do that
because i have my rights darn it i
thought this was america and no one
including my helpless little baby can
take those rights from me how about you
cut it out with the rights for a little
bit and consider duty consider
obligation consider loyalty consider
love consider anyone but yourself you
selfish
crazy young myopic
girl thank you for sending in that video
send in more crazy tick tocks and i'm
more than happy to knock them down
[Music]
[Music]
you